给大家分享一条干活 要求
注意我说的是 要求 江湖说的老伙企
多看两遍 然后完成了一个
每天写点什么 和其他人无关
我们先看两个字
一个字叫窮 一个字叫傅
窮怎么写呢
宝贝 现在有一个罢
有一个利
这个傅怎么写呢 宝贝一口甜
如果我们回到风电视社会
什么是关键资源 土地
打下去打什么呢 它土地呢
负人 拥有最关键的核心资源
以及保护它的能力 土地就是这个天
窮人的宋材资料是什么呢 是巴和利
所以呢 这个负人就可以邀请
我们窮人 巴和利
来帮自己中天
然后为他制复工钱
然后把中小两世
然后再卖给窮人
那个负人疼出更多的时间用来思考
有不要相信那个过去那个意言的这个
比如说说这个负人
好傻呀 窮人好聪明的
你会发现负人从小的时候
部分家里都有私书
窮人有几个上的起司书的
然后往前起锅 尽头公孕月华时来
公孕华时来
这个那个时候还就是负早就出来了
就是天不一定就出香港新的核心资源
什么呢 资本和使用
来吧 去哪什么呢 使用的 对吧
但是窮人好 所以个宋材资料没变
巴和利
然后负人就可以请窮人来自一个工厂工作
负人工钱
然后宋材主动性
卖给窮人
等出更多的时间用来思考
但是中间有一个分析
这个分析什么呢 过去无论是土地
还是资本也好 还是石油也好
都不是能够轻易获得的
但是有一个分析 就是软件
我以前是学建筑的
后来做软件了
有软件啊
他人在没有土地
没有资源
没有资本没有石油的情况下
用窗造力创造一块软件
让软件为自己出工出力
然后来展现 哇 这个很棒
好 我往前推荐 进化到第三个时代
第三个时代是什么呢 是信息时代
就很多人生活在信息时代
但是不理解信息时代的意义
昨天我就看到有人评论许有个人问我问题
结果他这个人就回答说
你脑子就甩了 你有问自媒体人
他们大部分能在别的行业干点啥
他也不会做自媒体
是这样
前面的就好是同意的
就人意调独立司法 后半人就好
我认为很多人和他一样
没有理解信息时代的本质
信息是带这个信息啊
他是消耗品
他是一种需求
就什么人都需要信息
有人需要
让我快乐 让我爽的
有人需要让我打到生意的
让我变得更聪明的更智慧的这个信息
所以有些信息不给钱
你都不能看
有些信息你给了钱
你都不一定会买得到
你看我们回到以前啊
你们负人
他拥有的生产这个资料什么呢
是甜
后来是资本
后来是什么
后来是这个
是有
信息时代什么东西是核心资源
是闯造力
是头脑 头脑变得更重要的
但是实际上这个手管程序平船
可以不去体会一下
窮人呢 没变
和0
所以
在信息时代有一个非常大的变化
这个变化给了很多窮人一个机会
什么机会就是你通过
8和0去完成一个机会
这个机会就是
让自己又有头脑
拥有窗造力
你去体会机会
让我们该怎么做呢
好 我们不说那么多了
然后给大家一本书
就是那个纳华尔
那华尔
宝殿里面有这么友好
我给大家读一读
你去思考一下
最好的工作
于委任或学位无关
昨天有人就在评论去够留言
有本事你给我门证明一下
你考个博事后
对吧
我们证明一下
我问问你
你也问问自己
我跟你讲
动气了这个问题本质的人
根本不需要通过委任的
或者学位来证明自己
事上昨天
你已经燃烧了你大量的时间和经历
来免税为我提供
生产资料
你忠祝吗
最好的工作
于委任或学历无关
是忠深学习者
在自由市场中的創造性表达
伤会